sophie marceau spielt elser allein
erziehende mutter die auf einer party
den verheirateten vater pierre
kennenlernen der bezirks- und erobert
ihr herz
schön dich zu sehen ja finde ich auch
mein partner und ich hier meinen prozess
gewonnen
hierzu treffen wirklich was willst du zu
trinken
die regisseurin lisa azuelos setzte in
ihrem film ein augenblick liebe den
zerstörerischen wirbel der liebe in den
konjunktiv bonbonbunten musik soße
getaucht und die liebe wird nur in
träumen erlebt während das leben ringsum
ungerührt weiter geht
doch das alles nun den köpfen der
liebenden stattfindet ist keine
entschuldigung auch träume verdienen
kritik
meister
die rolle für sophie marceau ist eine
zumutung
sie muss sich die etliche moral der
geschichte gefallen lassen und die
einfältigkeit des soundtracks
hinzu kommt das skript das nicht mehr
schafft als großen kitsch von der
hollywood stand
warst du musst ständig denken an dich
denken wie eine fata morgana
sophie marceau hätte der regisseurin
widerstand leisten sollen
doch sie dient ihr nur als
projektionsfläche